sac d'une manière générale dans le
contexte de crise économique et de
focalisation sera question terroriste
est question environnementale passe
largement après sauf quand les français
ont le sentiment qu'elles ont un impact
sur la santé et sur le diffuseur gpad
enquête en tête mais j'anticipe plutôt
une opinion favorable à son interdiction
qui se retrouvent en contrats existants
de contradiction avec les agriculteurs
maintenant nicolas hulot il est un peu
dans le même temps m
il ya le même enjeu qu emmanuel macron
c'est à dire faire imposer son point de
vue exister dans un contexte où les
français sont plutôt sceptiques sur la
réalité de son action et sa capacité à
faire bouger les choses avaient une
enquête ifop dans le jdd
la semaine dernière où on voyait très
bien qu'une majorité très nette de
français y compris des sympathisants à
blick en marche vous voyez nicolas hulot
plus comme une caution
et comme un symbole que comme quelqu'un
qui alla qui aurait la capacité de faire
progresser les questions
environnementales